[Music]
there's a uh 24 year old man who was
jailed for
stealing a puppy
worth uh thirty seven hundred dollars
can't be doing crimes like that man is
it a bulldog no jury is gonna everybody
that's over 999 dollars you need to get
the uh the image in order to give cute
contacts you always need puppies
stealing a puppy from a hoarder house
maybe like a maltese or something a
bulldog oh my god those are expensive 37
yeah so you so he was actually he ended
up stealing this puppy at knife point
and what he had what he had tried to do
what he had tried to do first was go to
this dog breeder all of them he went to
his dog breeder and he had uh just
[ __ ] counterfeit money super fake
counter for money this breeder catches
it
yes exactly um
it's not real on it specifically says
not real the breeder catches it and it's
like nah dude i'm not taking his money
so he pulls out a knife steals the puppy
oh we had a plan b
yeah why doesn't he just get the mommy
daddy dog and go sick um
that's a good question
that connection i don't know he's a
breeder right you got an army of dogs
behind them you got to let the dogs do
their jobs
wasn't there a show that like
experimented if your dog would protect
you if a burglar comes and i remember
like multiple times like the burglar
will come in and the golden retriever's
just [ __ ] shaking his ass like oh we
got friends though retrievers are not
protective dogs like that though they're
just they love everything this is good
you know most dog bites come from golden
retrievers really just because
statistically people own so many so it
just so happens that a lot of dog
fighters yeah excuse the numbers
okay was this guy a backyard breeder
like one of those illegal ones he's not
a breeder uh like he went to the guy
that the brit that breeder
degenerate backyard dude those some of
those guys are [ __ ] cuz [ __ ] those
guys too is he a super legitimate pet
store i'm pretty well this guy was this
guy was uh the breeder was advertising
puppies for sale online so i don't know
this guy pulls out his knife steals a
dog uh and then he gets into a car and
flees but the breeder was able to
identify the driver's license on the car
was able to trace it back to uh what
ended up being this dude's girlfriend
and then that was how the police were
able to convince the license plate dog
thief
dogs
i don't know how they got me yeah
but that's not the actual story of what
makes this interesting so this guy gets
convicted goes to jail
but it turns out
that he tried to escape this jail by
trying to
swap places with his brother
during the visitation
that's why you have brothers his
brother's tight dude that's what that's
what peterson's
this is a sudarso brothers story
i'll leave you tonight
me and my brother are going to go in the
kanji conjugal room
and then they [ __ ] switch clothes and
i'm down for that
kanji room i'm down here
i'm thinking about food you're thinking
about something else
thank you for being the only southeast
asian that understood that i appreciate
it
i thought that [ __ ] was called congee
oh when i saw that's the one you're
talking about
it's rice porridge right yeah
how do you guys pronounce it you guys
are just [ __ ] american
is how i say it oh
come back
just completely all right so this dude
is sentenced to five years in prisons
for his crimes right that's where he
hatches his plan to escape freedom with
the help of his brother so during a
family visit on april 11th he handed his
armband used to identify inmates to his
brother and hoped guards would not be
able to tell the difference between them
thus allowing him to walk out with his
freedom wow what if his brother's like
white and he's black or something and
it's like clearly different right they
just have different dads and [ __ ] or
whatever that's how they got caught they
were you know they're not gonna they're
not gonna know because they're gonna see
the [ __ ] uh wristband they're wearing
different clothes like we got different
wristbands and [ __ ] that that ended up
being the main thing obviously the
guards the guards were able to spot that
their newest inmate was wearing a
different set of clothes you weren't a
polo and they quickly put a stop to this
gate attempt before any secret hey
where's your orange jumpsuit bro
brother was down wow
that's a brother
or maybe the brother was the one who was
like hey can you get me a puppy no yeah
by all means necessary i see that i
think he's a bad actor i think he walked
in he's like well back to jail for me
hey jail bros ready to have some sex
where's the ranks going down he might
have been taking his acting classes
whose [ __ ] am i
his only like acting credit is under
ember hurts classes
or they actually did rape him and
they're like it's a lot tighter now than
it was earlier
and that's how i figured it out how does
it feel like
[Laughter]
why
wait so what was the conversation like
where his brother was like yeah you know
what i'll part-time jail for you you get
it off the thing too i know no have you
ever been to a theme park where maybe
you can do this with your hand and then
you do this with your friend
maybe it's a liberal jail it's one of
these one snaps on
your technology
it's like an honor system bracelet just
don't take it off
they're from the 90s this is how we
identify the inmates we're going to hear
the snap we'll know if you're switching
[Laughter]
or maybe when they were putting it on he
was like oh can you keep it like kind of
loose
i can't feel my hand i'm like oh my god
my hand's [ __ ] falling asleep i'm
gonna lose my [ __ ] hand
like why you gotta do it so tight and
then so they did it just to shut them up
loosen it and then they did this
handshake [ __ ] and they [ __ ] did this
thing like this
that's what juicy small aid happened
when he was in jail he's like jail's
[ __ ] hard this is [ __ ] so hard and
then they're like fine get out of jail
god god damn it
you get like 10 days or some [ __ ] yeah
dude he's out now i was hard though he
was in there for eight days and then the
judge was like
he's i guess he's freaking out yeah he's
kept on having panic attacks and [ __ ]
and so the guys
apparently all the guards were eye
rolling so hard that they just let them
out the guy the guy who faked the racist
attack on himself the actor the actor
the guy from the empire juicies
[Music]
he annoyed his way to freedom
he's pretty good at that bro he tried so
hard that the guards were like
judge please like get this guy out he
cries too much we can't sleep at the
jail and he thinks that solitary like
throwing
i don't think so i think he's just a
regular gen pop you know put up put him
in a sound booth he can't do anything
actually get out of jail though if you
annoy the guards enough
to get out of jail one is good behavior
and two is cry bad behavior
throw a tantrum 10 days that's all
that's it 10 days
i like i like his uh
theory i don't even know if he proposes
but you said it uh about the idea that
the other brother wanted the dog which
is probably what got that other brother
convicted which is why he felt bad so
he's like now i gotta take your place i
like i like thinking about it like that
because then it makes more sense
otherwise it's just a down-ass brother
and do you think too that he's like you
know what [ __ ] i'm old enough for
kisses i can go to jail yeah god damn
that is so disturbing though i'm pulling
up for kisses would your brother wanna
try this
shrivel inside of me i'm ready for this
lifestyle would your brother go to jail
for you would you go to jail for your
brother no absolutely not really no
you knew he was innocent
still no then i'll figure it out on the
outside all right that's smart he was in
jail for something that was related to
you because like you made a mistake yeah
because i mean you guys got caught
kissing in public impossible i'm perfect
so
have you watched prison break that that
show before
oh yeah that's what that show's about
that's true but he didn't go in place
with him no but he went in to go get him
out
i'll do that what if peter has he like
booked an awesome job and he needs to be
out of jail to work it and in the
meantime you you shouldn't have been
[ __ ] around
i swear we'll switch back i swear
as soon as i'm wrapped
after the wrap right here well there
might be a premiere
okay after the premiere i'm here to
premiere
you should as a good brother you should
take his role
you know what's funny is i don't ever we
don't go out for the same things anymore
so i wouldn't they'd be like oh no not
at all you guys don't go out anymore
at the same time though
that's such a cheap shot okay yeah i
like you put your hands back put your
hands apart were you both competing for
the blue ranger role or was it a
coincidence he went in for a green
actually
he was playing the like nerdy role and
then i went in for the the bigger wait
the green rangers and nerd now wait
isn't the blue range of the nerds i
switched
but why it's been 20 something seasons
you want the same story every single
year well the tommy was a green one that
turned white right they're old enough
dude so we did a whole video and uh yeah
i was taking a pretty big show in the
pirates i didn't know you're on the show
my apologies oh
even though we said it like seconds
before wait when yeah i was like when
you got the roll for the blue ranger we
were talking about the power rangers and
then the episode
in the same ever
i wasn't thinking about power rangers
for some reason
uh
that's fascinating so so are you like do
you go to the cons and all that [ __ ] no
not too many i've done like maybe three
or four you still have your suit
dude they like cut it up in front of us
what why what
they make a bunch of suits and then they
use it throughout the season yeah right
you gotta do is say it's morphing time
it'll appear back on
try it
we wore the suit like three times it was
mostly everybody else's like the stunt
doubles and all that stuff but they do
like 10 of them each for the whole
season and it gets ruined in front of
you like we were walking over that's
really dramatic and then they were like
oh that's this is what happens to him
i'm sorry this is your legacy
wait why do they do that they came
because they don't want people to to
sell it they keep like two or three to
do like appearances and stuff like that
and keep in the museums or whatever
wow
i guess that makes it easy to make like
you just hire somebody to make it did
you i know all those things as a youngin
yeah so we were like yo i'm a [ __ ]
power rangers is crazy yeah and i
actually i did like the live shows for
like three to four years
power interest
what was it when i was shot well for the
video was pretty
fun excuse me
[Music]
you